what marvel is including in the deleted
scenes
it's really going to be their decision a
whole 40 minutes of footage just didn't
get the raimi stamp of approval for dr
strange and the multiverse of madness so
we thought we'd open up that third eye
and take a look at what got cut
including that twist ending okay let's
go
number one doctor strange two was almost
a very different beast before sam raimi
came on board the man quite literally
scrapped everything after scott
derrickson left and started fresh and i
had taken a lot of time off trying to
refresh myself and
develop a new vision for things he had
the pandemic to thank for that extra
time to do so man is it not fun picking
up a project in the middle especially
one with infinite possibilities the one
big possibility that changed though was
wanda becoming a focus michael walden
said then sam and i had an opportunity
to look at each other and say okay
what do we want this movie to be we had
a chance to start over from scratch the
first big decision we made was what if
this was the story about strange having
to protect america as wanda pursues her
across the multiverse i mean it was very
surprising number two mordo had
initially taken far more beatings
michael had written an earlier scene
with the 616 universe version of baron
mordo where he was the morto that we
knew from doctor strange one trust your
teacher
only he'd been through many battles
since that framey said he had a limp and
he was coming after the scarlet witch to
take her power she cut off his head and
presented it to strange in a later scene
raymie continued it was really great
writing but it slowed the beginning down
too much so we had to lose it
i'm not a monster stephen
i'm a mother number three it must just
be terrible to be that one superhero
that can be squished by a couple of
fingers
inspired by the movie aliens a version
of wasp was in the illuminati and in the
first draft of raymie's version wanda
just clapped her hands and smushed wasp
flat it sure brings a lot of weight to
the phrase she wouldn't hurt a fly
number four this is the real spin-off
that fans have been waiting for
we love wong in every universe instead
of wanda throwing wong off the side of a
mountain in the first draft she wrote
wong's story to make him a vagus
magician turned action hero is that not
enough
instead of sitcom style she went for the
80s action style and he got nicknamed
vegas wong michael waldron said she made
wong basically into her henchmen and
rewrote him into an arnold
schwarzenegger in the 80s commando
predator style action hero and sent him
after strange that assault on the
illuminati headquarters was wanda but
then it was wong with like a grenade
launcher these are the things that make
their way into the first round that was
pretty good you happy
that's a
interesting question number five the
name melvin is perfect because it just
doesn't sound all that fantastical you
wouldn't hear of a show called the
marvelous melvin now would you and if
you did hear of it you'd think it was
some fringe performance and probably not
attend keeping up with the fake magician
types in the movie there was also a dude
named melvin strange a street magician
that guy's a magician he doesn't even
have a costume a steven strange without
any real magical powers it's pretty hard
to imagine in any universe that the most
egotistical doctor would ever be a
street magician is that guy a plant that
looks like a real punch
number six concept art doesn't always
tell the truth defender wong on earth
838 never ended up making an appearance
in the film despite being in the early
and gorgeous concept art for the movie
this also happened in chongqi and the
legend of the ten rings
i always bet on asian when there was a
bit of concept art that included
deadpool battling at the fight club
these pieces may have just been for
inspiration and never really included
wong or deadpool at all
i thought that was you
number seven you can't even call phone
ranger because your phone isn't working
better get a bat signal phone ranger the
canon superhero that protects telephones
for whatever strange reason almost made
an appearance in the movie and almost
had a painful painful ending i wrote a
near and dear character to my heart
phone ranger who's just a ridiculous
phone-based superhero but he didn't make
it in maybe he can also get his own
spin-off series repairing phones sounds
like an adventure we may see phone
ranger yet your fame is the only thing
protecting you number eight how do you
capture infinity in 40 seconds a james
turlworld didn't make the final cut in
the universe montage his work includes
capturing the essence of light simply it
really must be fun coming up with
different universes like in rick and
morty or everything everywhere all at
once how do you decide what stays and
what goes 20 universes in only 40
seconds and a whole world of ideas at
your disposal
rule number one of multiversal travel
you don't know anything
right
number nine why couldn't we have had
this version concept art shows charles
xavier saving wanda maximoff's life
while another evil version of wanda
stalks around the premises
and in this art xavier still got his
green jacket implying a different ending
was in store for him when the maximoff
your mind is being held hostage by your
alternate self
number 10. the elegance of the museum is
overstated how would the plot be
different if the location was different
more concept art shows professor x in
what looks like a spaceship rather than
a gorgeous museum what truth that's not
how our strange died
[Music]
number 11. we would like a long spin-off
tv show where every episode is set in an
alternate universe please another
version of the sequence would have
included wong helping wanda obliterate
the illuminati we're glad that didn't
happen we love wong too much to see him
be so cruel wanda on the other hand we
enjoy watching her destroy things
number 12. pizza papa's dreaded mustard
bottle was there to save the day bruce
campbell who played pizza papa had some
great takes that just didn't get used
you took this whole suit from the
strange museum didn't you sometimes when
you're coming up with comedic gold
there's only so much a scene can carry
gold is heavy in this case that golden
mustard bottle was fighting back come on
it's not permanent doctor strange
has not seen the last
of the pizza papa
number 13. way back when things were
simple i mean look i think we make a
great team an in-universe interview
includes strange and palmer talking
about their method for a moving part of
the spine to fix paralysis never made an
appearance in the film we wonder where
it was even going to go and while this
video was released with the second movie
we can't help but think it's a deleted
scene from the first nice save
number 14 it's close to midnight and
something evil's lurking in the dark the
original plan was to show 616 strange
trapped in the incursion universe while
sinister strange develops the third eye
and then in honor of michael jackson's
thriller they were going to use the
laugh of horror icon vincent price
evocative of the laugh in michael
jackson's thriller as the movie's final
note
number 15 this one turned out to be one
huge troll the interdimensional minotaur
was supposed to have a much larger role
in the movie and wanda was supposed to
face off against him the internet went
nuts over a media leak of long climbing
back up the mountain but by the time
they were doing reshoots this sequence
was left on the cutting room floor that
poor minotaur 40 minutes is a ton of
footage to cut seriously that's a whole
tv episode in itself what deleted moment
shocked you the most let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things